Này bà tháng tư tại Hanoi, bộ tư pháp tở trước lẽ khai chiêu nền tạng số thiện án dần sử,
giống mốt quan trọng cho tính trình trên đối số tạng diện của Ngài,
xuống tới mục tiêu quan trị hết đại, mình bài, lấy giữ liệu làm chúng tâm,
và phục bộng người dài tốt hơn.
Dựng bởi lẽ có ở vỷ biên chương vâng đàn, phó thu tưởng chính phủ hỗ phó giống,
bộ chương bộ tư pháp mỗi hải nền, bộ chương bộ phà học và công nghệ nguyễn mạnh hồn,
cùng đại dễ nhiều bán bộ ngành chương mơ, đại dễn khách tập đoàn dành nghiệp và các đường bị liên qua.
Sức đều tổ chức tiếp theo hợp chức tưởng tới bà mấy tư tình thành phố trên cả nước.
Nên tạng số thiện án dần sử dự xây dựng theo định dựng số hóa mốt chăm phân chăm quy trình như vụ,
hết nối chúng tâm dự liệu hô ra và hứng dục đình dành để tự viên ở ía đi,
và đạm dự lượng đúng đủ sải thống.
Hẹt thống thiết hợp các phần hệ tại chính kể tỏan khởi biên là định tự.
Chủ tích tập đoàn appetiti trên giá bình khẳng định,
cứ trên khai thành công hệ thống là mình chính cho tình thần đột kết tạo dựa
cơ quan và li nhà nước và dân nghiệp công nghệ Việt Nam.
Có phần hệ tự khóa nghị quét sủ nằm bây bây,
về đột phá phát triển phò học công nghệ và triển đột số khó ra,
thực hiện bệnh hành cho thấy từ thống 1 năm hình hôm 2.5 năm,
đến hế thống 3 năm hình hôm 2.5 năm, đã phát hành gần chỉ trong nghìn biệt lại định tự.
Tổng tư gần sống nghiệp tì đồng,
một trong phần trong quyết định thiền án được ban hành trên mù trường số.
Tại buổi lẽ, phó thu tự trị vụ khó khó số,
bố trường bố tự pháp mới hành niên,
bố trường bố khá học và công nghệ mệ mạnh hôm.
Không đại diễn dân giang nghiệp và các đơn vị liên quan,
các thực hiện nghiệp thức gần nước giả mắt nền tàn số thiền án dần sự,
này sống hệ thống chỉ thức ban hành trên mù trường số tòa của,
phát biểu tại buổi lẽ phó thu tự tưởng khó khó số kỳ nhận,
tính giả cao cuối tâm của tập thể ban thử vụ đạo quy vụ tự pháp trong chỉ đạo xây tự
nên tàn số thiển án dân sự theo hướng bài ban hóa học,
trên hai đồng bộ trên phạm viết tận của trong thời gian án,
và đạt được nhiều các quả tích cơ.
Mà tôi cũng xin đi,
hẳng lãng gián giao liên dương sự phía tâm,
lối lực của tập thể ban thử vụ đáng lý,
đáng đạo vụ tự pháp trong việc chỉ đạo xây dự vụ,
lần thử số và chỉ đáng những dự xử,
các tất cả hệ hống qua bài ban,
được chiến khai đồng bộ trên thử vụ tụ quốc,
và trong một người dành các kính mà đạt được gốc và hẳng bất tức cơ.
Vì lần các trái lâu là việc đưa nền tàn số và chỉ đáng cho sự hào hẳng hành.
Tốt giảy thế hình xin đổi mới,
nhưng thế giới,
về cân gài mà còn là sự chiến lỗi kên bán từ phương tức,
còn lý trình thống,
sàng từ thức bóan trị hiệ lại,
tên giữ liên số,
kết thọm và cập nhận thêm tơ hế tất.
Tự sự lý trụ công,
sàng ước dụng công ở phúc tiền,
và thì đại nhân cao,
chúng còn quý trình về phụ tệ nán kêu sử,
một lần bật,
khách sức là quan tâm,
bỏ đàn tinh tìm mình hóc lục,
tinh hiểu lực,
của và ngán và cất định,
tìm,
lần thẳng số và tìa nán kêu sửa,
được xây dựng và và hành,
và hình thần thêm thống cơ sửa chứ liên kìa nán kêu sự tập tuần,
cất đối,
liên không,
lúc phòng năng cao đến câm,
câm khai,
quên mặt,
bỏ tởi quả không các quán lý,
chỉ là ảo tí hoàn,
đong thời,
pháo tục lời hôm trên người dân,
dân nghiệp,
trong thực hiện quyền,
sạm ký vụ của mình.
Hó tự tưởng cũng yêu cầu buộc tương pháp tích tục chỉ đạo,
các đời bị liên quan,
phán thiện niên tàn,
bởi đạm vận hành ồn định,
an toàn,
tất cả nối,
chìa sẽ dự lượng,
và nướng cao chất lượng dự lượng.
Bộ triển buộc tương pháp mởi này nên trên trọng tiếp thù,
đồng thời mong muốn tiếp tục nhận được sự phố hợp chặt trẻ của các vụ này nhẹp phương,
và cậm đông dân nghiệp công nghệ để nên tàn số thiện nhắn sẽ sử,
phát vi hiệu qua,
tụi buộc tốt nhất người dân và dân nghiệp.
Bởi tất sự,
hôm nay,
nằm một ngày rất buổi,
rất là tự hào,
đối với buộc tục pháp nói chung,
này ghiền nhắn sẽ sử,
nói dương,
sau một năm,
cũng đã rất là bất bả,
đã sắp cánh cùng với buộc năng,
buộc phóc nè,
với tập bỏng FTN,
và khá các lúc chi ở tiền nhắn,
dân sự có việc phương để xây dự,
nên tạm số về tiền nhắn rất sử này,
rất là tập chất và hiệu qua,
một tập pháp xin rất trọng gà mơ và sịt tiếp tù đầy lù,
các ý kiến chỉ đạo của đồng chi có tụi tốt chi vụ,
và sẽ chỉ đạo cuộc của đi tình nhắn rất sử,
cuộc tẻ qua thành tế hoạch,
giải pháp cuộc tẻ,
góc mình mâm tóc hiệu qua,
rất là thật đất,
tệ nhắn rất sử,
và phải nó lần,
mằng sự hai lòng của người rất cũng ngươi rất,
và thật quả,
thông qua thực hiện các chi vêu gần đẹp mần tiền,
lựa bố hội và chiến của giao,
tinh trở trọng và mơ tâm chi.